RFK when I interviewed him the first
time three years ago during covet
I never thought he's going to run like
that was never like rfk's gonna run and
I don't even know if he wanted to run I
don't know you know how some people for
years like DeSantis I feel like he's
been wanting to run his entire life
Hillary I feel like she's wandered her
in her entire life Mitt Romney yeah I
feel like a lot of we can't give a list
you know who these guys are on the list
totally I don't think our kid was on
that list I don't think he cared to run
you know want to do it vivec maybe I
think Vivek is ambition is enough to
think that he thought he would be the
youngest president ever I can actually
believe that I'm 50 50 there
why do you think of vivec
that's almost passed up the scientists
okay why is vivec and RFK why are they
doing so well uh in this election why do
you think they're doing so well yeah two
totally different reasons so uh and I
pulled this and I haven't told anybody
about this poll before and I'll tell you
uh on the Democratic side there is a
great hunger for someone who is not Joe
Biden now that's a well-known fact but
we polled it and almost every anybody on
a one-to-one matchup against Biden like
you could put in Bob Smith Jim jablowski
made up names
yeah we should actually do it Ronald
Paul and put Jim Jones and don't trust
me they would yeah there's a random guy
in Wisconsin named Jim jablowski he's
like I'm running for president yo and we
did it we did that poll included I put
my new own name in I put in a bunch of
progressives all of us got 20 or higher
yeah okay you're right there's a
yearning for him not to be the president
yeah RFK is is not actually popular when
when I I talked to Marianne Williamson's
campaign but you said RFK is actually
not popular yeah so they just don't know
who he is they're not going to him
because of his anti-vaccine stance
anti-establishment stance they're going
to him because his last name is Kennedy
and they're like oh that's better than
jablowski stop guys Adam you're saying
that is true it is true you know I'm
saying his last that's not I'm not
agreeing that it's the only reason
the other Kennedy Republican on the
other side with the accents related
he could have been a comedian he's
hilarious but that's why he was elected
Pat because he sounds like uh
but he's actually not a Kennedy so uh
anyone there so and by the way can RFK
Jr and Marianne combine have about 20
points like
they're 20 of Democrats are like I'll
give to anyone not named Biden I know
one percent of that is RFK in 20 of his
money that's that's true to be fair but
to be fair Kennedy's a giant name versus
Marianne and Mary has been smeared by
the media
Etc right so but if you're saying is
there an anti-establishment vibe in the
Democratic party hell yes hell yes it's
larger than 20 why do you think Bernie
almost caught Hillary and by the way he
should have been the candidate he should
have been of course of course Hillary
Hillary did her due diligence to the DNC
and they screwed him that was his chance
yeah and look I said Bernie could win
back in 2013 three years before he
closed a 50-point lead right yep and why
because there's this great hunger for
don't give me fake politicians yes and
they all they have all these stupid
mythology That No One Believes oh Joe
Biden's the boy from Scranton now he's a
boy from Washington DC yeah I mean we're
not blind we saw him in Washington
Scranton in 60 years
No One Believes that horse crap like
come on oh and I bought corn pop and
shut up so like nobody a lifetime Ago by
the way shockingly the core mom story
turned out to be true rules I couldn't
believe it by the way binding lies all
the time in the mainstream media covers
for it big time so yes there's a hunger
here's the goat of that area though
right line would you say you'd put them
at the top as the goat no Trump's always
stop no are you kidding me Trump
doesn't use it every every speech he
ever gave teleprompter was written by
somebody else
plagiarizing it no no but but there's a
difference between known lying and not
known lying like Trump is knowingly
lying whereas Biden had just literally
forgetful and defense
guys don't ever I I'm I'm putting my
foot down here don't ever ever undermine
the goat of all time of lying President
Joe Biden don't ever do that again
that's an insult this is a guy that does
it in a way I never thought oh my god
look on his face
did you put Newsome on the list of the
of the people that yeah yes what do you
do Newsom did uh better than the rest
when we put a laundry list together yeah
but he didn't do but what I found
interesting about it was that he didn't
jump out like it wasn't like oh
Solutions Head and Shoulders above
everyone
well it depends so everyone in the
establishment look guys I I'll be honest
with you some people thought one of my
announces was that I'm going to announce
the run for president right and I
thought about it and I'll tell you why I
thought about it uh it's because this
this voting base is super hungry for an
actual anti-establishment person who's
actually Progressive right so rfga
Junior's got issues with Progressive
Marianne's a wonderful person but she's
mainstream media has done incredible
damage to her uh and her perception of
credibility right if you give me one
strong Progressive we'd run through this
field like a hot knife through butter
and we'd run through Biden Bernie
Sanders number one problem was that he
refused to attack Biden and we all know
this I know everyone in his campaign
they've said it publicly now they had
notes for him to go attack him during a
debate and he wouldn't do it and
honestly he prioritizes friendship with
Biden over all of his voters and so I
love Bernie but that broke my heart and
so if you said to me Bernie running
again I'd say no because he's not going
to run he's not he's going to get in the
race and then tell you Biden is great no
that's that doesn't help at all right
but he gave me one strong Progressive
and we could definitely beat by and I
got so desperate I thought about myself
right why didn't you uh so look there
you'd have to run as a third party you
can't run no Democrat I'd run as a
Democrat no way I'd run you'd get smoked
no I wouldn't you would get smoke no no
no you would get destroyed absolutely
they would never let a guy like I know
by they would yeah they would make you
look like yeah so look I ran for
congress once and I got eviscerated by
mainstream media people say hey why did
you get loose so badly well if I had
read at 5.4 percent no I guess I got all
the way up to 6.6.6 yeah
one of them was 5.4 then you went up to
six points you know why they still
didn't stop California is incompetent in
a lot of ways that the Democrats don't
acknowledge and they never stopped they
only counted 76 percent the vote if I
was Trump I would say I won okay no no
but why did I get only 6.6 because Los
Angeles Times New York Times CNN all
told people that I was anti-muslim
anti-semitic anti-black sexist you uh
into beastiality every lie in the world
and the New York Times printed it like
it was true and so what I would tell
people is if I saw that written about a
candidate I would vote against them I'm
originally Muslim I don't want to vote
against someone who's anti-muslim and
they never gave me the mic so they never
gave me an opportunity to respond and if
you don't have an opportunity to respond
and mainstream media smears you you're
done you have no chance at all why would
it be different in the presidential
because and I'll tell this to any
Progressive who's thinking of running
and who's got any kind of Courage okay
look guys the presidential level is
totally different there's all sorts of
press they CA they almost can't deny you
press here I am on this show I can go on
almost any right wing show I can go
almost on any online media show and so
could any strong Progressive you can go
on oan you can go on Newsmax eventually
you'll get on the Fox News look at what
vivex doing vivec was nobody nobody
nobody like let's be honest I'm 10 000
times more famous than vivec yeah before
we started right now yeah but not now
why because Rebecca's using media you
don't in the past mainstream media had a
monopoly and and during 2016 they still
had that Monopoly and so that's why the
Bernie run was miraculous miraculous and
the Press shut them out completely in
2015 as he's doing a historic run ABC
spent seven seconds talking about him in
Primetime news seven seconds they spent
more like all of the networks combined
spent like four times the amount of time
talking about Joe Biden who didn't run
in 2016 than they did about Bernie
Sanders who closed 50-point lead so the
mainstream media is the most biased they
and look they're tied with Fox News
they're all horrible but you give me a
strong Progressive you let me do
strategy for them and we will manage
that as a sister aggressive give me two
or three there's look this is the game
that everybody plays right so the minute
I name it a name everybody goes oh no
way it's a progressive real way oh they
have no credibility Etc so look I know
she lost two races right but Nina Turner
it and and those two races would be used
against her she lost two Congressional
races right who is that Senator Nina
Turner
she's a talker yeah rip Tina Turner
though the real one
okay yeah I'm familiar with her yeah
Nina Turner was the chairman of uh uh
one of the Chairman's uh you think she
has a chance to be the president United
States oh hell yeah dude okay so I know
but that's what everybody says no you're
no no no answers no you're 100 wrong
okay so you're buying into mainstream
media and I'll tell you why I know
the president of the United States right
there God damn right if she ran Jack
okay relaxed so no hold on hold on hold
on y'all no no but this is you
exactly what I predicted ahead of time
right here a minute ago okay the minute
I name any progressor you go oh no I
haven't heard of them no mainstream
media assistant oh no way no way hey she
doesn't look right I mean like you don't
even know
first of all just so you know I had no
clue what she looked like because the
only face I know is Twitter and the
videos there I go based on what she said
the stuff she says is super extreme
together no it's not I'm just telling
you from my side I'm watching what some
of the stuff that she says she sounds
extreme but go ahead and say why you so
she would have a shot she's
anti-establishment okay so if she was on
this show and maybe you should get her
on the show she would tell you things
incredibly similar to what I'm saying so
we don't buy in to establishment
Democrats we don't buy into mainstream
media and when we don't they smear the
living hell out of us okay they smeared
me they smeared her they smeared every
Progressive I'll name but I'll name a
non-progressive to catch your attention
because I you know because we've all
been brainwashed into thinking no
Progressive could ever win right uh Jon
Stewart he'd clean Joe Biden's clock
he'd beat him in Atlanta don't disagree
right I don't disagree so just give me
someone who's kind of progressive and I
will beat Joe Biden so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]